ابنه شقيقي ابو انجيلا المتهم بصنع قنبله
لوكربي يتحدث للعربي عن تجاهل السلطات
الليبيه لاتصالات الاسره
نيوزيلندا تفرض عقوبات على 22 المسؤولا
ايرانيه من بينهم قائد الحرس الثوري ورئيس
شرطه الاخلاق
وزراء الخارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبيه يبحثون
اليوم فرضا مزيدا من العقوبات على روسيا
وايران
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر نبدا
من ليبيا حيث عبر مجلس الامن القومي عن
الاستغرابه لمحاكمه ابو عجيله محمد محمود
في امريكا على خلفيه الهجوم او هجومي
اي مطالبات مرتبطه بهجوم لو كيربي وكان
ابو عجيل مسؤولا في جهاز المخابرات في عهد
النظام الليبي السابق وتمت ادانته بتهمه
لها علاقه بالحادث المميت الذي راح ضحيته
270 شخصا من بينهم 190 امريكيا خلال رحله
طيران بين لندن نيويورك
عبد المنعم المريمي ابن شقيقي ابو عجرم
متهم بصنع قنبله لوكيربي قال للعربيه ان
اسرته تفاجات بتسليمه للولايات المتحده
مشيرا الى ان الاسره حاولت دون جدول اتصال
بجهه الرسميه في ليبيا
ما توصلت معنا مجموعه
اللي هي المشتركه في مدينه مصراته
وفعلا ابنه
وبنته وزوجته
عنده مشاكل صحيه وفي اليوم
ثلاثه ايام مرتبه يعني واخذ دور برد ومريض
اليوم
34 عاما مضت على اعلى في حادث ارهابي شهدت
الاراضي البريطانيه تفجير لاكر به الذي
راح ضحيته 270 شخصه لتبدا معها محطات
القضيه الابرص انطلاقا من عام 2003 حينما
اقرت ليبيا بمسؤوليتها عن حادث تفجير
اللكربي في اسكتلندا
توهاما بالضلوع في التخطيط وتصنيع قنبله
تتعلق بالارهاب لمواطن ليبي يدعى ابو عجيل
مسعود المغربي
امنعم الجاري فشاهده نوفمبر الماضي احداث
متسارعه اعاده قضيه اللقبي للواجهه بعد
الجدل الذي اثاره اختفاء ابو عجيل مسعود
في ظروف غامضه تقارير اعلاميه قالت انه
خططف من داخل السجن بالعاصمه طرابلس بينما
ظهر بيان وعائلته انه اختطف من منزله
ليطالب بعدها المجلس الاعلى للدوله حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه
بدور الكاميرا
عبر بيان اصدرته وزاره العدل تطرقت فيه
لرفضها فتح ملف قضيه
معلمه انه اغلق بالكامل سياسيا وقانونيه
لكن دون ان تتطرق للتهم الموجهه لها او
ملابسات اختفاء ابو عجيله
اما روايه ابو عجيله فكانت مناقضه لتلك
الرسميه عائلته قالت في بيان انه في
السادس عشر من نوفمبر الماضي اقتحم مصلحون
بملابس المدنيه منزلهم في العاصمه طرابلس
واختطفوا ابو عجيله وقت عدوه لجهه غير
معلومه عزه اسرته وحينها اختطافها لاغراض
سياسيه ترمي الى الاضرار بالمصالح العليا
للبلاد
اخر محطه لغز اختفاء ابو عجينه كان في
ديسمبر الجاري بعد اعلان الولايات المتحده
ان المتهم المطلوب لديها ابو عجيله بترانا
الاحتجاز لديها دون ان توضح كيف وقع متهم
لكربي بقبضه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في جديد للاحتجاجات في ايران ابهر مقطع
مصور تعدي ضابطن في القوات الخاصه
الايرانيه على امراه اثناء مرورها في
منطقه سان بالعاصمه طهرا
في شيراز جنوب ايران تداول نشطون مقاطع
مصوره لاضراب النار في اعمده كاميرا
المراقبه
افادت مصادر ايرانيه بان السلطات تستعد
لتنفيذ حكم اعدام ثاني بحق احد الموقوفين
في سجن رجاء شهر ويدعم رهان صدرك
واستمرار ردود الفعل الغاضب على اعدام
المحتجي الايراني محسن شكري اعدام او
احكام الاعدام تاتي بالتزامن مع خساره
العمله الايرانيه المزيد من قيمتها امام
الدولار الامريكي اذ بلغ سعره صرف الدولار
حوالي
370,000 ريال ايراني
هذه هي سمه المدن الاراديه تظاهرات
متواصلات تحيط بالنظام وتضرب اقتصاد
البلاد المنهاري في مقتل في خضم عقوبات
تلو اخرى
ليتراجع الريال الايراني المتعثر الى
مستوى منخفض جديد مقابل الدولار مع
استمرار الاحتجاجات والاضرابات العماليه
والاسواق وتزايد عزله البلاد وسط
الانتقادات الغربيه للاجراءات الامنيه
الصارمه التي يتخذها النظام تجاه المحتجين
حيث كان يتم بيع الدولار بما يصل الى 300
الف ريال في ما ارتفع بعد الاحتجاجات الى
اكثر من
370,000 ريال
وفقد الريال قرابه 14% من قيمته منذ
اندلاع الاحتجاجات على مستوى البلاد عقب
مقتل سامي
قفزه كبيره انعكست هي الاخرى على ارتفاع
الاسعار مع عدم قدره النظام على دفع رواتب
المتقاعدين ما دفع بهم للتجمع في وقفات
احتجاجيه اضافه الى اضرابات في قطاعات
النفط والغاز
والبتروكيماويات في المحافظات الجنوبيه
احتجاجا على الغلاء والظروف المعيشيه
الصعبه والتاخر في دفع الرواتب
التحام التظاهرات بالاضرابات ذلك ما يخشاه
النظام الايراني الامر الذي قد يؤدي الى
شل البلاد وحركتها الاقتصاديه المناكه
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
فرضت نيوزيلندا عقوبات على 22 مسؤولا
ايرانيا من بينهم قائد الحرس الثوري
والقائد الامن الداخلي ورئيس شرطه الاخلاق
ومنعتهم من دخول الاراضي نيوزلانديه وذلك
ردا على العنف الممارسه على المحتجين في
ايران نقلت رئيسه وزراء نيوزيلندا الى
بلادها لا تزالوا تقف الى جانب الشعب
الايراني نساء والفتيات
من جهه اخرى يجتمعوا وزراء الدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي اليوم في محاوله للاتفاق على
مزيد من العقوبه على روسيا وايران ومن
مقرر ان يقرر الاتحاد عقوبه اضافيه على
شخصيات وكيانات ايرانيه بسبب تمرضها في
انتهاكات لحقوق الانسان في ايران
والارتباطها بتزويد روسيا بطائرات مسيره
داخل روسيا قال مجلس الامن القومي الى
موسكو تكثف انتاج اقوى وسائل التدمير
ملوحا باستخدامها ضد الغرب تصريح ان ياتي
والسماء خوف غربيه من لجوء بوتن لاسلحه
غير تقليديه ردا على تراجع قوته في
اوكرانيا بينما يرى مراقبون ان روسيا
تستخدم سياسه حافه الهاويه للدفع نحو
المفاوضات
عسكريه في الاشهر الاخيره في اوكرانيا
اعاده موسكو لمربع التلويح بتسالته
النوويه في محاوله لتغيير وضعها الميدانيه
عدونا ليس متواجدا في الخنادق فقط في
محافظتك انه موجود في اوروبا وامريكا
الشماليه واليابان واستراليا ونيوزيلندا
وغيرها لهذا نقوم بتكثيف انتاج اقوى وسائل
التدمير
روسيا تقول انها ستلجا لمبادئ جديده لم
توضحها لكن الحديث على الاغلب يدور حول
تكتيك الترهيب الروسي لشبح الحرب النوويه
في محاوله لفرض صفقه مع الغرب الرئيس
الروسي بلادي مربوط باستخدامه تحت ذريعه
ان السلاح النوويه يعد وسيله الدفاع
الغايه منها توجيه ضربه الانتقاميه في حال
استهدفت بلاده بهذا النوع من الاسلحه
وروسيا تعمل على تعديل عقيدتها العسكريه
بالاعتماد على الاجيال الجديده من الاسلحه
التي فوق وسرعتها سرعه الصوت حسب البيانات
المعلنه للتسلح النووي العالمي منها التي
نشرتها منظمه ايكان فان روسيا تمتلك اكبر
ترسانه نوويه في العالم اذ يبلغ عدد
الرؤوس النوويه الحربيه لديها سته الاف
255 راسما نووويا منها
1588 جاهزا للاطلاق معظمها صواريخ موجهه
لاهداف بعيده المدى وعدد اخر اصغر حجما
واقل تدميرا تستهدف الاهداف قصيره المدى
في ساحه المعركه او في البحر
وسط التلميح النوويه الروسيه الدول
الغربيه تقف ممدده باستخفاف روسيا بخطوره
الوضع محضره نياها بعدم استغلال محادثات
سلام اوكرانيا كغطاء لاعاده التسلح او
التخطيط لهجوم اكبر
وبالحديث عن المفاوضات اعلن وزير الخارجيه
البريطاني جيمس كليفر ان اي محادثات بشان
اوكرانيا لا يجب ان تكون فرصه لروسيا
لاعاده تسلح وفقه تعبير
انني جاي شيشن
ولا يمكن ان تكون مجرد ورقه لاعاده التسلخ
الروسي وتجنيد مزيد من الجنود سواء من
مجموعه فاجنر او من السجناء في روسيا نريد
ان نرى محادث سلام لكن يجب ان تكون ذات
مغزى وفي النهايه يجب ان يقرر الشعب
الاوكراني والرئيس الاوكراني محتوى
محادثات سلام هذه وهي العتبه التي يمكن
تحقيقها فيما يتعلق باحلاله
تسبب القذف الروسي المتواصل في انقطع
الكهرباء عن جميع مرافق البنيه التحتيه
غير الحيويه في مدينه اوديستا الساحليه
جنوب اوكرانيا الهجوم روسي تم بواسطه
الطائرات مسيره ايرانيه وادى الى تدمير
المنشاتين للطاقه ما تسبب في انقطاع
الكهرباء عن مليون ونصف مليون شخص ليعتبر
اسوا انقطاعا للكهرباء في اوكرانيا
بعد الضربه الليليه التي شنتها طائره
ايرانيه بدون طياره يخيم الظلام على
اوديسه ومدينه وقرى اخرى في المنطقه وحتى
الان اكثر من مليون شخص في منطقه اوديس
بدون كهرباء
نشاطنا مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
المانيا تصادروا اسلحه الف عضو من جماعه
الرايخ وتتعهد بتشديد قوانين السلاح بعد
المحاوله انقلابيه
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت الحكومه الالمانيه
اعتزامها تجديد قوانين حيازه السلاح بعد
المحاوله الانقلابيه لحركه مواطنين وقالت
وزيره الداخليه الالمانيه نانسي فزر ان
هذه الحركه تمثل تهديدا متناميا للبلاد
نظرا لتساع قاعدتها من 2000 الى 2023 في
العام الماضي واشاره الى مصادرته اسلحه
اكثر من 1000 من اعضاء الحركه لكنها 500
اخرين على الاقل لديهم تراخيص سلاح في
البلاد
اعلنت النيابه العامه البلجيكيه توجيهه
تهملي اربعه اشخاص واحتجازهم لاستمرار
التحقيق معهم في قضيه الفساد بالبرلمان
الاوروبي وقال مصدرهم قضائيا لفرنسبريس
انما بين المتهمين ايفا كايلي وهي عضو
البرلمان الاشتراكي اليوناني واحد نواب
رئيس البرلمان وقال المدعي العام انه تم
تفتيشه منزل عضو ثاني في البرلمان
الاوروبي للبحث عن ادله
داندي
يوصل رجل الاعمال ومالك تويتر لهم ماسك
فتح الممارسات السريه داخل الشركه
والاحداث التي وقعت قبل حذف وتعليق حساب
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب على
تويتر وكشف الجزء الرابع من التسريبات
التي نشرها ماسك ان الرئيس التنفيذي
السابق لشركه تويوتا
عندما تم تعليقه حساب الرئيس السابق
[موسيقى]
كما وعد قبل اسابيع غرد الى الماسك الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركه تويتر والصحفي ماكل شلل
برجر الجزء الرابع من الملفات الداخليه
لعملاق وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
لاحداث السادس من يناير في مبنى الكابيتال
الهند
السابق لشركه تويتر
بويقافه فورا ونهائيا من الخدمه
تغيير في السياسه لانه في حاجتين حصلت في
الفتره هذه اولا انه جاك دورسي ما كان
موجود في تويتر همم خلال الفتره دي فهو
كان خارج البلد ثانيا انه كان في ضغط من
الداخل ومن الخارج هذه الملفات ولم تمر
مرور الكرام لدى الحزب الجمهوري والفريق
القانوني لحزب المحافظين الذين اعتبروها
ادله تثبت المخاوف التي صرحوا عنها في عده
مناسبات حول كونهن ضحايا للقوائم السوداء
والمنع من التعليق والحج على المنصه على
عكس شهادات المديرين التنفيذيين للشركات
في جلسات الاستماع في الكونجرس السابقه
من البيت الابيض سوف يكون له ولفريقه ورقه
يستعملها
ويعزز مواقع اذا تم الهجوم عليه قانونيا
او سياسيا فهو لديه ورقه كبيره كبيره يقول
انا كنت تحت ضغط وتدخل الاجهزه المركزيه
او الخصم السياسي لترامب وبالتالي هذا سوف
يخلق بخ يعني بقناعته واقع جديد في العمل
هذه التسريباته اظهرت كيف تم تغيير
السياسه الداخليه لحظر حساب الرئيس السابق
ومنعه من التغريد على المنصه واحده وبشكل
متميز عن بقيه القاده السياسيين الاخرين
حتى اللحظه خاصه مع سياسه عدم التعليق
التي انتهجها الرئيس دونالد ترامب حول
الموضوع برمته منذ اعلاني لهم ماسك من على
حضرتك حساباته حتى هذه المعلومات التي
ربما لم تكن خفيه لدى البعض ريتا سليمان
العربيه واشنطن
[موسيقى]
اثار عرضه وثائقيه عن الامير هاري وزوجته
ميجا ماركل على منصه نتفليكس الكثير من
الانتقادات وقد شنت عده صحف بريطانيه
هجوما على الثنائي وذهب البعض الى حد وصف
ما جرى بالخيانه الملكيه
خلال الاسبوعين الماضي
حادثه العنصريه التي طالت مساعده
حتى اعلنت منصه نتفليكس عن وثائقي هاري
ومجد هذا الوثائقي الذي تصدر عناوين الصحف
كافه بلا استثناء وهو ما قد يتسبب بصداع
للعائله الملكيه التي عاده ما تتجنب
الحديث في امور العائله الخاصه
ايه ده ده عرس السعاده
الاولى لا تقلوا عن ضجه الاعلان الترويجي
الذي تزامن مع زياره ويليام وكيت الى
امريكا فاراء الثنائي في العائله الملكه
ستنفرت مؤيدها لاسيما في وسائل الاعلام
صحيفه المترو ذائعه الصيت والتي توزع في
القطارات سنه هجوما عنيفا على هاري وماجد
سائله اياهما هل تضعان المال قبل العائله
واجابت عنهما قائله انه السؤال الذي لن
يجيب عنه
على صفحتها الاولى ايضا فالى جانب صوره
لهاري والملك الراحله طلبت بايقاف ما
وصفته بالخيانه للملكه الدينميل والدليل
الملكه الراحله في حين تحدثت التايمز عن
انزعاج القصر من الوثائقي وما تضمنه
[موسيقى]
واو
المسلسل صحوف التابلوت بشده كما ينتقض رفض
العائله حمايه من ملاحقه الاعلام لها بحجه
ان هذا ما يحدث لكل اللواتي يرتبط
بالعائله ويتحدث هاري عن فخره بان اطفاله
مختلطوا العرق وكيف انه فعلا مثل ماذا
وترك كل شيء لاجلها اما ما كان فتبدو
شديده النقمه على العائله حيث تقول انها
مهما فعلت كانوا شيء يجدون طريقه لتدميرها
في الوثائقي يبدو هاري ماخودا بوالدته
وبتشابه بينها وبينما من حيث التعاطف
والحنان ومن حيث الثقه والدفء هل يقول انه
سيفعل ما بيوسعه لتجنب تكرار سيناري
والدته مع عائلته الحاليه هو لا يريد
للتاريخ ان يعيد نفسه وربما ذلك هو
المفتاح الذي ادخله القلوب الكثيرين الذين
احبه دائما
بعد فوز اسود الاطلس على البرتغال بهدف
دون رد في كاس العالم
2022 في قطر حقق منتخب المغرب مجموعه من
الارقام القياسيه رافقت انجازه التاريخيه
بالوصول الى نصف نهائي كاس العالم نستعرض
هنا قائمه بابرز الارقام القياسيه التي
حققها منتخب المغرب بفضل مشواره المميز في
المونديال الى الان
[موسيقى]
بمشاركه اكثر من 350 شركه خاصه وعامه من
15 دوله حول العالم انطلقت في العاصمه
الفنزويليه تراكاس مناطيد الهواء الساخن
في اكسبو ترانسبورت فنزويلا الدولي 2022
[موسيقى]
هبطت مركبه اوريون الامريكيه بسلام في
المحيط الهادئ بعد رحله تجريبيه الى القمر
وبحسب وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه ناسا فان
هذه التجربه ستمهده في المستقبل القريب
الطريقه امام رواد الفضاء في الرحلات الى
القمر وجاء هبوط المركبه اورينت على الارض
بتزامن مع الذكرى الخمسين لهبوطه 17 اخر
مركبه فضاء ماهوله وصلت الى القمر قبل 50
عام
في نهايه الشهر هذا التذكير بابرز العنويه
ابن شقيقي ابو جيل المتهم بصنع قنبله
لوكربي يتحدثون العربيه عن تجاهل السلطات
الليبيه الاتصالات الاسره
نيوزيلندا تفرض عقوبه على 22 مسؤولا
ايرانيا من بينهم قائد الحرس الثوري ورئيس
شرطه الاخلاق
وزراء وخارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبيه يبحثون
اليوم فرضا مزيدا من العقوبات على روسيا
وايران
متابعه والى اللقاء عند المتصفح
[موسيقى]